it took Congress only three days to
provide billions of dollars in disaster
relief for hurricane ravaged areas in
Texas President Trump made a deal with
Democrats to raise the debt ceiling
through early December while provided in
providing much-needed relief for
hurricane victims the Senate and the
House quickly passed the measure which
mr. Trump signed into law Friday
Paula Reed is live at the White House
with more Paula good morning good
morning President Trump is spending the
weekend at Camp David where he is joined
by several members of his cabinet
hurricanes will of course be a major
topic of discussion there today both
recovery efforts from hurricane Harvey
and preparations for hurricane Irma
President Trump in the first lady left
for Camp David Friday afternoon before
boarding marine one President Trump
assured reporters that the u.s. is ready
for the pending storm
with cleanup efforts from hurricane
Harvey running out of funds and
hurricane Irma barreling towards Florida
states are looking to Washington for
money on Friday morning the House passed
a disaster relief package providing more
than 15 billion dollars in aid with
broad bipartisan support the yeas are
316 the nays are 90 resolution motion is
adopted shortly after President Trump
signed the bill in a tweet the White
House press secretary said it will
provide much needed support for storm
survivors what we're seeing in Florida
though are fuel shortages the
president's Homeland Security Advisor
Tombaugh cert said the federal
government is waiving restrictions on
foreign fuel deliveries making it
possible for non-us ships to deliver
fuel to Florida amid widespread
shortages as many ships tanker ships as
possible or not being brought to bear on
the effort to bring as much fuel as
possible and to help Floridians the
president used his weekly video address
to urge people in impacted areas to take
evacuation orders seriously I ask
everyone in the storm's path to be
vigilant and to heed all recommendations
from government officials and law
enforcement last night the president
tweeted that he believes churches in
Texas that helped out during hurricane
Harvey should be eligible for FEMA funds
several churches have filed lawsuits
over restrictions that typically prevent
religious organizations from getting
that FEMA relief Dana
Paula Reid at the White House Thank You
Paula